this is grandma everyone oh yeah looks
like feeling 40 years gang gang
identical and I love the furniture set
in the background tune yeah it's just I
don't want anything to match in my
apartment ever nothing and can we what
else do we know about this beautiful
well this picture was taken on her 86th
birthday and she is 92 now today Wow oh
yeah all she wants to do is smoke a cig
and get drunk off one glass of wine she
loves to dance and do crossword puzzles
and she wore high heels to the hospital
after breaking her hip that's gangster
dude well first of all when you're that
age every book is a crossword puzzle you
know what I'm saying
life's a crossword yeah when you're 92
the road is janga for you you know like
you're just gonna pull the wrong thing
and break your hip yeah she's yeah when
you're trucking around that 92 year old
risky biscuit you know what I'm saying
here you might run into some everydays
crunchy peanut
she looks very nice she looks like the
kind of lady who like she runs the Mafia
commands attention yeah she looks like
she could just clear her throat and spit
into a pot and it would just be a great
recipe of ravioli or something she's got
that kind of just that vibe that vibes
like she gives out change on Halloween
yeah just a white lady right good to
give you money but also secretly to
weigh your bag down a little bit just so
she can chuckle a little bit gonna be
struggling down the road just knowing
she put some weak kid up to you know got
87 cents of weight on a weak kid who
looks like she has a lifetime supply of
graham crackers yeah that's what you got
excited yeah she looks like she
definitely you know in Ephrata to get a
man off if she has to abide you excited
by any means necessary she looks like
she means business
oh she looks like she'll blindfold you
and just kick you in the dick till you
ejaculate she got that room some people
are into that man oh let's go to the
culture corner for that cat what do you
know about that kick into the pic well
just like foreign types of getting
people off kind of you like people offer
Cal a lot of money to look at their feet
oh yeah do you know that no well now you
do go on okay I've got some weird offers
some people are
into feet I don't get it kind of their
offers did you get some guys actually
get kicked in the nuts yeah I've gotten
offers for photos of my feet old socks
I've asked somebody has asked for like
two week old socks before oh yeah shoes
this is not American um
pictures of my dad's feet - oh wow okay
a father-daughter feet porn or just yeah
I think asian feet are in high demand
right now what'd your dad say was he
open to it or he's thinking about it oh
wow yeah he said he'd get back to me and
do you do a lot of cam modeling or
anything like that get oh no okay
I kind of wish I did though yeah I can
see you doing something I can't erase
there we can't do that here and we don't
do that kind of stuff so you can't do
that here cat well you could yeah where
were you Sadie what do you think this
old lady we have the lady or the cat
it's B what are we talking about I don't
even know shout out to this old lady
staying alive smoking cigs
what else we got forensic hits all the
buttons that are on the table even if
they're not for him call button button
mashing visit broccolini get your life
together